roaming millennial joins in studio to
talk love in the age of Trump then
Arielle Davidson and Amanda presto
Giacomo joined the panel of deplorable
z-- to discuss revived Obamacare repeal
North Korea's rocket man burning his
fuse out there alone and why teenagers
aren't having sex drugs and rock and
roll anymore sad now before we begin
here I would just like to address
something once and for all people have
been insinuating that the only reason
that I do this show is so that I can
bring in a beautiful women and talk to
them every single day and obviously
nothing could be further from the truth
before we begin roaming can I get your
glass of Malbec I would love that that
is great and fellas seemed seems a
little bright here to do an interview so
okay yeah that's a lot better that is
much better
so what let's just dig right into this
interview roaming what's your sign our
cancer
you're kidding that is such a
coincidence I also have an astrological
sign oh my gosh no way
[Music]
Cheers
[Music]
mmm so what uh what is your favorite
color
M&M why don't we both say our favorite
colors on the count of three okay that
sounds fine
one two three red it's just like
something's happening here yeah
definitely
how's your fiance
[Music]
we're joined today by roaming millennial
roaming thank you for being here
this is roamings been with us from the
beginning one of the first people on the
panel of deplorable I think I might have
been not on your first show but one of
them you were at least on the second
show second or third and we you know you
bring up my fiancee obviously it's from
getting married to sweet little Lisa
next year but the rapture is happening
the rapture is coming on Monday
according to Christian numerologists so
if we're gonna start the doomsday
right-wing apocalyptic polygamous cult
now would be the time to do it speaking
of some time polygamous organizations
you went to BYU that's right I am NOT
Mormon but I went to pretty much the
biggest Mormon University but you're not
Mormon so I'm curious about your your
religious views and I'm also curious
about why you chose BYU why you chose a
mormon school so I'm born-again
Christian I chose B while you because it
I studied Middle East Studies in Arabic
as my minor and BYU actually has an
amazing Language Program so I went there
to study Arabic and you know I got a
scholarship there it was very lucky it's
a good school academically but it is a
warm in school and not being Mormon
there were definitely challenges yeah it
does definitely what sort of challenges
um well everyone's Mormon they all super
want you to convert to Mormonism you
have to take Mormon religion classes
while you're there regardless of where
they're Mormon or not so I pretty much
have in essence a minor in Mormonism but
I know if you go to a UK public school
you have to take Islam classes so it
certainly makes just as much sense actly
the state religion of course um yeah and
they're just socially there were things
that you know Mormons are I have a lot
of Mormon friends but there are some
things that's like yeah they are a
little different especially the ones in
Utah mm-hmm
do you find because I haven't seen
you're talking about religion a lot but
we like to talk about religion and a
show do you first of all what is your
religious view um it's like I said
born-again Christian um I don't it's
actually funny I don't really talk about
religion on my channel just because I
have a pretty wide variety of watchers a
lot of people who listen to Maher
actually you know very liberal or maybe
more libertarian than I
um so it religion isn't something that's
come up but I think more and more I'm
starting to see how I guess my religious
views kind of I mean they're not
determining for my political views but
they definitely kind of go together they
influence one another and things like
there's a foundation that's exactly so
what are your religious views let's
break the news here you don't talk about
it on your channel we need we got to get
some views yeah well I mean I definitely
believe in God and I think the idea
behind Christianity a lot of people who
aren't Christians aren't very familiar
with Christianity and how its practice
isn't the idea that you be a Christian
that's all about being perfect but it's
the idea that there is forgiveness for
sin and I think you know the idea behind
sin and just knowing who I am as a
person and you know all my own flaws
that's kind of what made me attracted to
Christianity in the first place because
if you look at all the world religions
you know they all try to offer I guess
you know a form of self-help or
self-improvement but Christianity is
really the only one that says yeah
you're never going to be perfect but
here's what you can do about it so you
said it goes hand in hand with your
politics I have two questions and one
how does your religion influence your
politics and maybe vice versa and also
do conservatives have to be Christian or
Jewish or religious is there a room for
atheists in the conservative movement
well for me it's funny because I grew up
in a kind of Easter Christmas Catholic
household a big wheel dude yeah
god I love those two holidays and only
those but receive is good too because
you get all the feels right that's kind
of like a second one but yeah when I
when I was younger I mean I've always
I've never been liberal I've always been
pretty conservative just of how my
parents brought me up so you know it's
not like if I were to be an atheist I'd
be this pink haired overweight feminist
right it's not there but I think since I
kind of started exploring Christianity
more from a philosophical theological
standpoint I've come to see more that
there are two realms and I you know I'm
libertarian my form in my view of
government but I think very much so that
just because we are permitted to do
something by government that doesn't
mean we shouldn't so I think that's why
religion and having these moral
questions are so important and I think
from a moral standpoint
what I think of as right and wrong
politically and even in my own life
that's where I guess my faith really
plays into it do you think that's where
the millennial generation and the
younger generation are this kind of
libertarian relation to Christianity or
or is it something different yeah are
they are they the nuns are they really
atheists or are they just reaching for
something that they weren't raised up
with I think they're reaching for
something I think that's why
libertarianism more so than conservatism
is being popular because if you look at
libertarianism I mean pretty much all
where a lot of conservatives embrace
small government principles but the I
guess what I see is the big difference
with them and libertarians like the I
guess small government conservatives and
the fact that small government
conservatives still will be very much
against things like drug use you know
and libertarian not personally just for
the for the law right I'm sure they're
all you know like we used to smoke pot
on this yacht according to vicious
unsubstantiated rumors that are totally
not true
probably not true yeah and I think
that's one of the biggest differences
and I think when we're looking at this
younger generation who is more
conservative leaning than any since what
is it the 60s or something like that I
think they're on their way there right
they see the dangers of large government
but I think where we need to do better
as conservatives is teaching them like
yeah government should be out of our
lives but we should still kind of
restrain ourselves and here's why here's
why this is not morally good for us to
do even if no government is gonna be
telling us not to do it so do you think
I mean you would call yourself sometimes
a libertarian sometimes your concern I
would say conservatory and I would never
just say even when I talk about
libertarians and I say like oh I lean
libertarian because when I think
libertarian I just think you know Gary
Johnson and lizard people know roads
smoking pot I don't know that's my
you're obviously you're talking about
the theorem of the reptilians do you
what you're questioning that settled
science no I'm sorry okay all right well
maybe we'll get to that later with the
panel but it there does seem to me
sometimes the libertarianism is a
cop-out and a little bit I think it's
why college kids lean that way is
because you can say look man yeah I want
lower taxes but I'm at liberty I'm not
one of those big bad conservatives do
you think that libertarianism is a step
on the road to being more of a
mainstream conservative or is it really
its own
category I think it can be a step on the
road toward mainstream conservatism as
long as we you know if you have that
foundation where you don't have got like
the state doesn't have the right to
interfere your lives you know there's no
good to be had from wealth
redistribution things like that but it's
on a step I mean a step on the road to
conservatism but I think the the extra
thing that needs to happen is that you
have to be asking yourselves these moral
questions like alright well if the state
isn't there to tell us what to do does
that mean we just do whatever live this
crazy and cap life or are you know are
we still operating on your assumption
that there are things that are right and
wrong in our lives and if so what are
they how do we know what should guide us
in that and I think that's where church
comes in and Jett Dennis Prager talks
about this a lot and I think it's such a
true point small government only really
works under under I guess the guide of
these I guess religions and faiths that
kind of keep us in check because the
government isn't there you need a big
God to have a small govern exactly yeah
I think that's totally right it does
remind me that the libertines ism of PGR
works sa where the title of the essay is
I think I might be misquoting it how to
drive fast on drugs while getting your
wing-wang squeeze to not spill your
drinks there it is poetry and that is it
does kind of embody that libertarian
mindset I think the only reason I would
oppose legalizing marijuana is because
of all the people who want to legalize
marijuana just to spite them I feel that
when you encounter these people that's
all they care about yeah I mean III
there was a bit where I was getting my
immigration together where I was going
to the courthouse a lie went like three
times and every time I went there was
this guy trying to get us to sign
petitions to legalize marijuana it's
like a you clearly already do it so you
know no worries there and B this is this
really something you want to Center your
entire life this was the same guy yeah
it's like the most important thing
forget about national security free
about tax reform talking about health
care it's just legalizing pot now if so
libertarianism might be on the road to
conservatism there is this thing that is
not on the road of any of those things
it is a it's an alternative and you've
gotten in trouble with these guys yes
it's the alternative right and you have
talked to them you've talked to Spencer
I have personally talked to Richard
Spencer I've interviewed other all
rightie type people on the show
do we talk about them too much there
were like five hundred of these people
right I mean if you ask Hillary Clinton
there's 66 million of these people but
they're all anyone who's not Bernie
Sanders or the right of sense yeah if
you're if you're the right of saviors
you're on there all right yeah but in
reality how many of these people are
there five hundred or something yeah
they're they're a group that is
extremely vocal on the Internet
like screeching lis vocal but in real
life I think you're right they do make
up a very very tiny portion of the
population they're not this major
political movement that the left tries
to make them out to be they're not the
reason why Trump won but at the same
time I kind of get what you're saying
right we don't want to build them up or
give them more attention than is due but
with the way the alt-right term is being
thrown around I do think it is important
for conservatives or anyone who's not
out right but being labeled are right to
say hey by the way this isn't us like
this is what these guys think and this
is why we don't agree with it I'm amazed
that the left I mean this is what they
do right they've done this forever they
say there were three racists in the
country and so we're gonna paint the
whole Republican Party's races but with
the alt-right at least those guys are
honest the 500 feet they say it's all
trite it doesn't mean very right it
means an alternative to conservatism an
alternative version of things so I guess
you're right you do have to point out
why they're wrong their ideas are
illogical they're easily very they're
very emotional and people ask me why I'm
not all right I'm not all right for the
same reason I'm not a feminist or a
black lives matter advocate right
because there are emotional arguments
based on identitarian ISM and like I
have a lot more things to be proud of
and committed to than the color of my
skin right yeah it's nothing I don't
feel that I've accomplished very much
for that you also have this other issue
with the all right which is that you are
not all white yeah complicit in the
white genocide or you are the white
genocide yeah roaming how dare you yeah
I mean I I feel bad for you know they're
clearly upset about this but you know
Here I am planning to I guess have all
these mixed-race children so I guess
it's it's really uh you know what I
think though I think we need to amend
their they have this slogan which is the
the fourteen words we must secure the
existence of our people and a future for
white children it
just add a hyphen in there and say white
Asian children right you're in there
you're and then you're good then you can
fit in there we would get along totally
fine if only that were changed and you
get it you get a ton of flack from these
guys oh yeah because it is pretty
strange you only started doing this a
year and a half ago and now you're like
the biggest thing on YouTube you you but
you grew so fast you get a gazillion
views what is it about you why do people
watch you that's and that's something
that I've asked myself a bunch right
because you know I kind of watched my
videos and these are these are kind of
nice subjects right I mean things that I
think are interesting but yet I feel
free to actually drink the wine I'm
really I'm taking the game there's a
license to drink during the show it
seems great yeah I'm not sure I think
part of it is that you know people are
looking right now for someone who isn't
isn't afraid to be called all these
names and just express themselves so
that's why when you see anyone who's not
afraid to do that Ben Shapiro is a great
example of that people are kind of a
dream but yeah so people are drawn to
that and then hopefully they're they
look at my channel and see someone who I
really do care about these issues and I
you know I see myself as sort of an
activist for you know conservative small
government principles and I hope that my
videos are informative you know I'm sure
a lot of people will say I'm only
popular because I am a girl I you know
what I'm not gonna say that has nothing
to do with it I'm hoping that's not the
only reason why people what are you
saying that if I identify as a girl at
all I'll finally get as many views as
you that is how that works a woman I am
a beautiful woman you identify as
Angelina Jolie yeah that's right yeah at
least at least my cousin Beyonce yeah so
on that point they say it's just cuz
you're a girl and it is true pretty
girls do very well on YouTube
particularly in the conservative
movement they do very well on Fox News
and on television stations but that's
fine it seems to me use any any tool at
your disposal to talk about true ideas
the left always gets conservative women
wrong they don't understand conservative
women because they under the
conservative women are supposed to be
barefoot and pregnant in the kitchen and
never leave and never utter a word but
you don't do that when I think of
conservative women
Margaret Thatcher Phyllis Schlafly you
and Coulter laura ingraham on and on and
on I love that I'm included with
Margaret Thatcher just equally same
level same amount of okay yeah yeah I
mean I don't know I haven't seen
Margaret Thatcher put out a YouTube
video probably ever alright she's really
slacking mm-hmm absolutely
what but those are pretty tough ladies
those are tough cookies yeah you're
right you're an outspoken fierce
defender of your ideas yeah why do they
get women wrong and you know I get
people on the Left attacking me for that
reason all the time oh if you're so for
Family Values and you why why are you
not you know pumping out children and
stuff like that and by the way I'm 23 I
think I think I've enough time to do to
do both well Monday is actually so yeah
but I think the reason why there are a
lot of these conservative women who are
so outspoken is that I think you know
terms of gender roles I think
conservatives in general embrace the
idea that you know men and women are
different in some ways you know and
they're complementary and so I as
someone who is a woman and conservative
I feel like I kind of care about these
issues in a maternal way and so I you
know I can't speak for any other
conservative female commentator but I do
kind of see it as a I don't know not a
way of mothering everybody and try to
tell you what to do but I feel like you
know if you really do care and you care
what kind of world your children are
gonna be brought up in if you kind of if
you care about your community and your
church then these are things you'll want
to speak up about it and conservative
women in general I think embraced that
and you know just because you want to
have a family and that you you know your
feminine doesn't mean you have to be
like what the alt-right thinks of as a
woman you know this hashtag tread life
where you're actually are barefoot in
the kitchen right they seem to be in
every way the all right seems to be
cartoonish oh but they do they talk
about the trad life and they do appear
to have cartoonish views of everything
including gender roles but obviously we
know as conservatives I always think
there are like three levels to this
there's the liberal level which is
completely wrong and then you know that
says gender roles don't they don't exist
whatsoever they're completely
meaningless men and women
exactly the same but if you're a man in
a woman's body then somehow you know
even though they're the same then
there's the next order which is the
conservative view and that view is men
and women are different they're rigid
these are the women you know and then
there's the higher level there's the
highest level of conservatism which is
like women you know there's it's it's an
appreciation and it's a playing around
with rules that are meant to be broken
and understanding that we live as real
people with real living ideas and the
way I see gender roles is that look I'm
a woman and I'm even as I'm starting to
get older I'm sorry to realize that my
priorities in life are like where I see
myself in the next five years
our next five days yeah I don't know how
I can convince you of this roaming
you're right I have to fly back to LA if
it is not and by the way in the death
cult we are going to make them where the
hands made stale costumes so yeah I
noticed you were trying on other
costumes and Steve Crowder's show last
week I'm gonna be like an Arabian
princess I was so jealous Crowder that
was a great bit though and happy this is
this is changing the subject just
slightly but you did this great bit on
Crowder's show and you sang and you have
a great voice and there you know
everyone goes on everybody's shows so
you go on the crowd or show you go on my
show will go on in two clave and show
whatever we are dominating the Internet
as conservatives conservatives are
killing it on YouTube and Twitter that's
where we live why is them what is
happening now is it is it something that
is it just a new version of something
that's always been around or is this a
real moment of cultural lift for the
white I think right now what we're
seeing is a backlash to the left ISM
that's been pushed down people's throats
and so I think I honestly love Trump or
hate Trump I think he's kind of the
embodiment of that right I don't think
Trump won because he's this policy
savant or because he's people Savior I
think it's because people are really
upset with the establishment right now
and the way things are going especially
when you look at leftism and how this
leftist globalist I guess point of view
where that's gotten them and
I think the popularity of like your show
daily wire in general I think that's
kind of reflective of that and what I'm
hoping is that I'm not sure that
everyone who is watching these
conservative videos is a conservative
themself I'm hope I'm hoping that you
know they kind of watch it and take take
away what the core message of like
constitutional conservatism is a
judeo-christian values and stuff like
that but at the very least because of
this backlash it's getting getting more
attention to what I think are some
important issues I don't think everyone
who's watching it right now like I said
is it concern of themselves but I'm
hoping it's at least a step in the right
direction right step one is make people
interested and watching your show right
then and why would someone who's not a
conservative watch this show or watch
your channel or watch any any number
crowd or van or drew it seems to me it's
because they've never heard these ideas
before these ideas are shut out of their
curricula in high school in college
they're told it's a thought crime you're
not allowed to discuss them and so when
a smart girl talks about it on youtube
you'll watch it right and I think the
fact that the left is always calling
people like you and me Nazis white
supremacist stuff like that I mean at
the very least people are gonna be
interested right like oh really they are
these modern-day Nazis are they actually
in league with Richard Spencer and you
know all of those Charles people and on
the very least it makes them interested
and then I think when they watched our
stuff and then see oh wait that's not
you I think it I think it kind of
trigger something in them like oh well
you know if this wasn't true what I've
heard about conservatives without
actually seeing them like what else have
I been told that's based on these
leftist stereotypes of not actually
reflective of conservatives that's true
and it's very hard to convince someone
to read Russell Kirk or Edmund Burke
it's kind of dense guys but it's easy
enough to get someone to watch YouTube
right and that's that's the way in
before we cut to the panel of deplorable
z-- we have to have the roaming
millennial lightning round okay I have
arranged the most important questions
some are dichotomies some are just
regular questions I want the first
answer that comes to your mind you know
don't think it out just let it come come
right out and this I think will give us
a portrait I think roaming millennial
his favorite youtuber it's our kind of a
cod favorite now what about me I guess
I'm not really YouTube you'd favor
novel I'm you should say favorite novel
see that's really really harsh for
strolling part part of me is day by day
Armageddon a zombie novel the other part
of me is I really like Pride and
Prejudice it's I pass too many although
I'm prejudiced I believed that I could
see that a mile away
favorite movie um I want to say
something profound and intellectual
seeming but honestly Lord of the Rings
the second one the second you know I
walked out it was so bored in the woods
we'll talk about it later for she and
her read it read it
Spencer Clavin or Richard Spencer um Oh
Richard Spencer because I want to
convince some of the beauties of
race-mixing a noble and and thing that I
don't want to think about Holy Quran
Duran Duran Duran Duran all right all
wrong my country right or wrong my
country went right my country run right
when right William F Buckley William F
Buckley William F Buckley always you're
just going right for it very courageous
political views favorite color well
somehow - - what a coincidence we've so
much in common
celebrity crush Bear Grylls great
senator Graham senator oh that that's a
hard one um Rand Paul maybe read plainly
progressed yeah Michael Lee is a hottie
Rand Paul I feel like he's got a good
heart
Wow Orange Crush were great Crush Orange
Crush no the correct answer was great
favorite philosopher um Smith in terms
of Governments Aquinas in terms of I
guess the nature of man typing he's
still my beating heart
mercy to the guilty is cruelty to the
innocent if you've never read any Smith
and no one has keep that in mind
everyone reads Smith that's kind of the
intro everyone says they read Smith how
many people on earth have ever read The
Wealth of Nations they've read about it
but how many people actually I feel like
any you know like 100 level Western
philosophy or intro to government class
you have to read well Yale the only
mandated classes are oppression and
Gender Studies
so that would be that's progress no not
to rate class yeah now that's gonna
replace the whole curricula weirdest
thing a youtube commenter has ever said
or asked of you
all right there are quite a few
questions about my feet about your feet
yeah like I'll be on a live stream and
there
we'll be a sizeable amount of people
asking me to show them my feet that is
does this come out if your political
discussions that you've been is this
esoteric well yeah maybe that's just it
Occam's razor well that is pretty I
never get those questions I mean it's a
part of me like oh well it could be
worse the other part of me it's kind of
like maybe it's it is that much worse
I'm just not seeing it yeah that's
that's true it seems innocent on the
surface maybe maybe a really deep
political question underneath maybe just
kind of weird how much go FEV a would a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could
cook-off FA a big Li amount thickly
absolutely right she nailed it
absolutely right we have got to say
goodbye to YouTube and Facebook now I
know you want to stick around we have
Ariel Davidson coming up I think we lost
Amanda so it's just gonna it's just me
Ariel and rubbing Millenial we're gonna
have an intimate close discussion about
all of these great things that are going
on Donald Trump's incredible speech at
the UN among others but if you want to
watch it you have got to go to daily
wire calm
daily wire calm right now it's ten bucks
a month 100 dollars a year you get me
you get the Andrew Clavin show you get
the Ben Shapiro show forget about all
that this this tumblr the unrivaled
greatest vessel for leftist tears in the
entire country
it's actually the leftist ears tumblr it
is indestructible because it's made out
of crushed up steven crowder mugs we
crush down and melt them down to their
core essence and we and we build this
tumblr it holds your leftist here's hot
or cold always salty and delicious you
got to go over there right now daily
wire calm we'll be right back
[Music]
it is time to talk about the undead
zombie back from life and for that we
cut to our seniors zombie correspondent
Bob Hope there yes maybe you know what a
zombie is when a person dies and is
buried seems a certain Buddhist priests
who have the power to bring him back to
life
it's worse than horrible because a
zombie has no will of his own you see
them sometimes walking around blindly
with dead eyes following orders not
knowing what they do not caring even
like Democrats
[Music]
it is like Democrats it is like the
opposite of Democrats because Obamacare
repeal is back from the dead what a
grave-robber
miracle of miracles Lindsey Graham
Lindsey Graham who expected that maybe
repealing Obamacare the Graham Cassidy
bill may do it before the September 30th
deadline because the Senate's
parliamentarian informed the Budget
Committee that the Senate only has until
September 30th to repeal Obamacare with
a simple majority to discuss we bring on
our panelist Ariel Davidson Ariel is
this going to happen I hope it does I
mean I think this is the gops chance to
really shine they've been for lack of a
better word deplorable in that category
when it comes to your feeling Obamacare
I think the whole dreamer situation has
been a tremendous distraction for lack
of a better word for Congress and so I
would like to see this happen I'd like
to see a repeal of the employer and
individual mandate
I think the imposition are imposing a
per capita cap on Medicaid will be a
tough sell but I think there are a lot
of parts of this bill that could be
extremely successful um you know
National Review had a great article
about this that came out at least a few
days ago talked about how this is a
great win for federalism and I couldn't
agree more
now roaming is this random is this just
a totally random thing or is this the
for DHS that we've been hearing about oh
god I love that forty chest I'm not sure
honestly I
I support Trump oh we're all in general
not crazy about everything he does but
the whole situation with the dreamer and
all the conversation that was you know
with Nancy Pelosi apparently convinced
him that dreamers are amazing and that
they should be welcomed and he was
tweeting some very curious things about
them that kind of smelled like amnesty
at least people like me I'm not gonna go
so far as to say that this is a way of I
don't know maybe the GOP trying to say
like oh by the way we are still in some
ways conservatives like at least a
little bit I hope it I hope it works out
would be great if they could do it with
a simple majority I don't know if people
like John McCain are gonna let them but
40 chess match I'm not sure I mean you
know sometimes where things just go
so bad that it kind of from afar looks
alright I think this this might just be
what the GOP is that it can't get any
worse yeah there we were hearing for so
long Trump is gonna do it he's gonna do
it on day one wasn't able to do it on
day one then six months in he wasn't
able to repeal Obamacare because of
people like John McCain and he was I
mean we react so quickly to Donald Trump
we rely react in such a huge way such an
outsized way but I wonder it took Barack
Obama 18 months to pass the Affordable
Care Act it's much harder to repeal an
entitlement than to pass one so maybe
we'll give him the benefit of the doubt
we were told a couple months ago that
Obamacare repeal was completely dead it
was never gonna happen now it looks like
there's a chance that this thing will
come back to life Arielle is this
should we give Donald Trump more time
more of the benefit of the doubt or has
his time run out I think we should give
him the benefit of the doubt here and
I'll tell you why I think that one of
the most successful things you can do in
your first term as a president is to
really pick two or three issues that
you're gonna focus on you know Trump ran
very hard in immigration it looks like
he's not totally winning on that
frontier right now for lack of a better
verb but I think his ability to focus on
health care now will be a crucial
turning point or at least an inflection
point in his presidency and will really
show whether he can focus his agenda on
that focus on that and focus on tax
reform because those are kind of got
going to go hand in hand especially with
looking at sort of what those on the
left end of the spectrum are kind of
coming up with and short in order to
fund their like Medicare for all plans I
don't know if you caught Bernie Sanders
idea of hiking taxes up to 52% to pay
for his health care plan
referre listen wants more taxes what's
apparently is breaking news Bernie
Sanders wants to raise taxes because of
these grand new ideas like socialism you
know those brand-new 200 year old it's
like socialized I've worked amazing yeah
like all the youths Bernie Sanders Yeah
right well so I I hope that it works I
hope that Trump is able to get this done
and really show that he can focus his
agenda in order to accomplish things
it's not like Trump has a lack of ideas
there's plenty
good points and plenty of good friends
to him for him to fight battles on I
just hope that he chooses his battles
wisely and this is one definitely worth
choosing so I hope he's able to focus
himself on it and get it done very good
ideas and the best words and he is using
those best words in his first appearance
at the United Nations Donald Trump made
it to the UN and he did not disappoint
some of the quotes are the Iran deal was
one of the worst and most one-sided
transactions quote major portions of the
world are in conflict and some in fact
are going to hell in America we do not
seek to impose our way of life on anyone
but rather to let it shine as an example
for everyone to watch and then he
addressed North Korea no one has shown
more contempt for other nations and for
the well-being of their own people than
the depraved regime in North Korea it is
responsible for the starvation deaths of
millions of North Koreans and for the
imprisonment torture killing and
oppression of countless more we were all
witness to the regime's deadly abuse
when an innocent American college
student otto warmbier was returned to
america only to die a few days later no
nation on earth
as an interest in seeing this band of
criminals armed itself with nuclear
weapons and missiles the United States
has great strength and patience but if
it is forced to defend itself or its
allies we will have no choice but to
totally destroy North Korea Rocketman is
on a suicide mission for himself and for
his regime you can't help but love the
guy you can't help but look at him and
just let rocket man is on a suicide
mission doing so well and he did better
he's doing so well
so much better it you know it obviously
it had the Trump aspect to it he said
that he he didn't want war but he would
totally destroy North Korea the entire
country and he obviously called Kim
jong-un Rocketman
but he also made some interesting points
that do have signals for American policy
changes he said that America does not
seek to impose its will on any nation
but rather will shine as a beacon for
the rest of the world which is harkening
back to a traditional idea of America
that we don't go gallivanting around the
world but rather the Statue of Liberty
is looking out casting its light on the
rest of the world from America Ariel did
he make the right call in using this
kind of language was this the right
message or was it bellicose and
irresponsible I you know I think it was
the right message I think it was on
point I think you have liberals shaking
in their boots over it it's sort of an
interesting selected memory that those
on the Left seem to have they're you
know they're being hypercritical at this
point when in reality we've had everyone
from Obama and Clinton who have a
President Clinton who have threatened to
destroy North Korea in some capacity so
this is not unusual language you know
it's starting to it's not even starting
to it's just more evidence for me that
it's not necessarily what Trump says
that'ss could be wrong for the left it's
just the Trump is saying it so I think
you have to take a lot of their
criticisms with a grain of salt and
recognize that you know they're doing
sort of ad hominem attacks on Trump and
you know I think he was right in line
here I think dying it's his we're no
longer going to be sort of this nation
that's somewhat of a pushover we're not
going to tolerate these threats coming
from North Korea and longer we're going
to be responsive and that's sort of what
you if you want to be a you know the
owner restore American hegemony you need
to think about restoring you know
restoring our image on the global stage
so he's he's trying to do that he's
trying to reassert ourselves as a
superpower so I I got his message of his
own point but to restore that image to
restore that credibility you have to
back up to talk with action roaming is
it to borrow a phrase for president
Trump all talk and no action or is he
willing to back this up and is he
willing to push toward regime change in
North Korea or to forcing them to
abandon their weapons program you're
like every time I'm on the show you're
always asking me if we should at you
know in some capacity use military
action against North Korea a theme here
it's because you're are you're half
asian correspondent right so we
obviously far-eastern issues with you
and we're as bloodthirsty as any other
show on the internet right of course do
we have to go to war
you know what this North Korea is
something I wasn't in support of their
wars in Iraq or Afghanistan as one of
the few things I disagree with ben
shapiro about but when it comes to North
Korea the thing is we're not dealing
with a rational actor right there's no
information asymmetries that we could
correct where it's like oh you know
we're actually willing to do this and
you know therefore bluffing with these
about these weapons of mass destruction
is it going to help you well this is a
very different situation kim jongwan and
the North Korean regime in general has
shown himself to be extremely aggressive
to United States not very willing to
compromise enter negotiations on good
faith and so you know if there was ever
a reason I've said this before if there
was ever a reason for military action it
would be against North Korea and I see
this is someone who doesn't want war it
isn't a hope for but increasingly I'm
not seeing any alternative for us and I
think Trump is smart to be trying to put
this pressure on China because right now
I mean North Korea is its own basket
case economically right they can't get
their own people so the fact that we do
still have places like China that are
doing trade with them I think really it
is really artificially propping them up
and you know if they didn't have that
extra trade financing perhaps they
wouldn't be able to you know spend this
money on nuclear weapons development
which incidentally I also believe comes
from China aerial president Trump
brought up this question of trade he
said the countries who trade with North
Korea are unforgivable they need to stop
it was this a speech threatening
military action against North Korea or
was it threatening economic action and
trade action against China I think it
was you know seeing economic isolation
which is something we see constantly are
frequently new sanctions is the way of
you know let's go through the process of
economically isolating this country in
order to correct their behavior
I will at work I don't know this is one
of the situations in which you know the
North Korean economy is so fragile
because it's completely state-run and
you know most of the I don't know what
percentage of the country but a large
fraction the country is enslaved to the
government so it's very tough to say
sort of predict how the economy will do
in North Korea in response to being
economically isolated but if that is the
route we go I see this sort of a method
of you know let's let's try these other
methods before we escalate the situation
to military action so I think I do think
it was a good call on Trump's part and
I'm I'm hopeful that this will this is
sort of the nudge and the push that will
get things done without having to
escalate the situation further because
you know as Romig pointed out you know
North Korea is an unpredictable
irrational actor despite what keith
ellison might tell you that that you
know he's a very you know that kim
jeong-hoon is a responsible leader I
don't know if you recall that video that
quote by keith Ellison had where he said
you know leader of North Korea was being
more responsible than Donald Trump
it means just send Dennis Rodman over
there to North Korea I think he's
offered actually he should is he did a
much better job than Barack Obama or
Bill Clinton that is for sure
with Barack Obama's strategic patience
policy I think Dennis Rodman's dying is
here and playing basketball policy is at
least as effective can be less can't
possibly be less effective but we need
to talk about something much more
important than a potential nuclear
holocaust and perhaps more dire when it
comes to sex dating and drinking 18 is
the new 15 for American teens that's a
headline out today there's a study out
that shows in 1991 the majority of teens
in high school 54% were having sex
another quote rather high percent were
drinking going out doing drugs had a job
by 2015 that number had fallen to 41%
those poor kids Arielle what does this
say about these youths these days I
think there's two things may be going on
I saw a good phrase being tossed around
on Twitter the extension of adolescence
so we just have children or teenagers
not really
in teenager behavior too later on you
know Millennials being sort of or the
next generation after as being sir the
toddle generation I mean we are as well
but um this idea that parents are just I
don't know what you what makes you think
that we're a coddled generation area so
there's that going on I think there's
this level of coddling that's taking
place which is actually stunting the
maturation of teenagers in general um
but I think there's also an economic
argument to be made here and it's maybe
a little more covert you're starting to
see the minimum wage rising in major
cities San Francisco they're planning on
raising to $15 when you do that you
actually cut out a large large part of
part-time workers and so what a company
will do is they'll lay off a time
they're low skilled workers an order and
just hire you know two or three
medium-scale of high skilled workers to
replace all those part-time workers or
the law like McDonald's has done in
cities around the country
although undue automation so it's not
doesn't surprise me that the teenage
employment rate is so low I think it has
a lot to do with the job of you know the
job market in general and how we're
starting to see you know automation is
replacing these jobs because companies
don't want to pay increasingly higher
minimum wages so I'm a huge proponent
you know avoiding this minimum wage
craze across the country because I think
what it ends up doing is hurting job
prospects for younger kids that is a
real insight because we always hear that
when you raise the minimum wage that
hurts low-skilled workers that hits
ethnic minority or disenfranchised
people but it certainly hurts 15 and 16
year-olds those are gonna be the first
workers to go because they just aren't
worth $15 an hour absolutely in the CBO
actually put this out in their report I
think in 2015 they talked you know this
is one of their warnings is that
companies will do this they will fire
low-wage workers and a bunch of them and
replace them with just a few medium
skilled or higher skilled workers so
we're starting to see the impact of that
now with higher youth unemployment
roaming another theory on this that some
social scientists are positing is that
because teenagers are using their cell
phones all the time
not going out to talk to their friends
they're going home and they're texting
or they're posting photos so they might
appear to be more risque or more
scandalous but they're actually behaving
in the manner that they're portraying at
a much lower rate do you think the cell
phone is what's killing the rebellious
nature of teenagers well I do think that
because we have social media and
television shows that are I'm sorry but
edging closer and closer to actual
softcore porn by the day it is like a
lot of the mystery but behind these
behavior is partying drinking sex drugs
it's actually being lifted and so I
would disagree with a lot of people that
drinking later and having sex later
means a delayed maturation I don't think
there's anything necessarily more mature
about having sex when you're 15 rather
than 18 or the same thing with drinking
and so I mean I personally see it as a
good thing and I don't think it
necessarily means you're staying a child
for longer it just means you're choosing
not to engage in these behaviors which
you know honestly when you're 15 16 17
18 you don't need to be doing and you
know it there there is this kind of
mystery behind it like oh this is what
all the adults are doing this is
dangerous this is fun maybe I can do it
and you know with social media the
internet I think more and more people
are sitting like it's not that exciting
it's not that glamorous if I'm not ready
to do these things or if I don't want to
do these things there's nothing nothing
pushing me to do it I can you know stay
at home with my friends you know on I
don't know what the latest messaging app
is for children but yeah I could just do
that there's no reason why I need to be
out late at night doing I guess
mischievous things roaming you're just
so virtuous I sometimes wonder when I
had these all-female panels of
deplorable --zz I don't really worry
that a perspective is missing but I bet
on this issue if we had a couple guys on
here they might take a slightly
different point of view but probably
yours is the more correct and virtuous
one Arielle you brought up this
interesting point that this is just a
process of delayed maturation so it
isn't just about teens going out late
and drinking it's about a delay across
age groups right so they're becoming
adults later too right so I mean this is
so what I would say is the same study
also posited that there's a large
fraction of high
schoolers have never been on a first
date so I'm not even talking about you
know sexual activity that's a personal
choice I'm talking about kids actually
forming relationships with other kids
and this could be a symptom of you know
our texting culture our social media
culture where you don't actually have to
have a face-to-face conversation with
someone um and so I think there's
actually this strange sort of social
ineptitude that's taking unfolding with
the younger generation you know I I say
this as someone who has a younger sister
who's a sophomore in high school you
know I see it within that generation
that a lot of their communication takes
place over electronics as opposed to
face-to-face let's carry this forward
and look at the average marrying age
which seems to be increasingly hiking it
seems that people are putting off
relationships in general there seem to
be less of a necessity for it if we want
to use the word necessity um so yeah you
know I'm not saying here I'm abdicating
that sexual activity as a sign of
maturation but I think that were in here
Arielle Davidson says that sexual
activity is a sign of maturation that's
gonna be a slogan I'm sorry go on you
know I just think that going on you know
your first date that is sort of you know
a crucial or pinnacle moment of your
high school career perhaps if it happens
for you then and to see that rate
declining so rapidly makes me wonder you
know the propensity of younger kids to
actually form real relationships with
their peers so um I think it's it's a
little bit alarming from that standpoint
I'm curious to see what the marriage
rates look like in ten to fifteen years
what the irony age will be then um okay
that point does make me a little
skeptical today of people who get
married very young at 20 or 22 not that
was common in the past but in the past
it was also common for fifteen year olds
to work and sixteen-year-old stag job
and to do things that adults do but at
this point if adolescents and teenagers
and young adults are having their
maturity pushed back so much then it
seems crazy to say you're you're not old
enough to have done anything that adults
do be financially secure have a job do
all of the other things that adults like
to do but you are ready to make one of
the
important decisions of your life there
are clearly side-effects of this that
raise difficult questions you know for
an aging population population that puts
off having kids and and we don't have
that much time guys because as I keep
reminding you my world is ending on
Monday that will be the rapture so maybe
we'll be able to fit it all in by then
yes not will at least get two more shows
in the meantime Ariel thank you for
being here roaming thank you for coming
on the show and for that it was a really
know it was just something really
magical about that that little I'm
getting yeah cheers to your health thank
you and thank you we'll be back tomorrow
this is the Michael Nolt show I'm
Michael Knowles
come back tomorrow we'll do it all again
[Music]
[Music]